s
d'autres à Chisinau, la capitale
de la Moldavie, mais ce centre
administratif est
particulces jours-ci.
ANDREI BIRLADEANU,
Moldave étudiant en France
- Et là, il y a plein de monde
le passeport pour pouvoir sortir
de Moldavie.
- Andrei, un jeune Moldave
étudiant en France a lui-même
ses documents. La crainte que
la guerre en Ukraine débor
en Moldavie, le pousse à mettre
fin plus rapidement que prévu à
- Poutine, je sais pas, il peut
penser, peut-êdedede venir même
en Moldavie. Ça se fait très
facilement, il est juste à côté
a quelque chose, je ne pense pas
que on a libibibibilité de
riposter. Donc chez nous,
il va rentrer très calmement.
pays limitrophes de l'Ukraine,
lavivivivie ne fait partie
ni de l'OTAN, ni de l'Union
européenne. Et un autre facteur.
- Dans ce petit village
se souvient encore de la guerres
l'indépendance de l'Union
soviét
d'années.
- Au début des années 19
Victor a combattu des forces
séparatistes appuyées
"Nous savons ce que veut dire
la guerre", lance le vétéran qui
a perd
Les images venant d'Ukraine
évlqlqlqlqlque chose de
particulier pour lui.
- Dans ce coin d
le conflit a laissé plus que
des souvenirs.
qui possède un musée dans le
village dea a a a a Noua, nous
emmène jusqu'à la frontière de
la Tra
autoproclamée proche de la
Rufofofofofoforces russes y sont
même stationnées depuis
Il y a une présence de l'armée
ru
se trouve tout juste à côté
ION STEFANITA, propriétaire
- C'est juste à côté d'ici.a a e
pour la Moldavie.
se trouvent donc à proximitéles.
Les autorités de Transnistrie
s'impliquer dans le conflit U U,
un rien pourrait tout faire
basculer- Ça peut commencer dane
seconde des conflits
de la guerre ici.
- Une vulnérabilité que
moldaves.
Nicu Popescu, ministre Aff
étrangères de la Moldavie
- On est moins protégés par
internationales, je dirais qu'on
est le pays le voi
fragile de l'Ukraine.
- En plus d'enjeux liés
moldave prévient que la guerre
en Ukraine actctctctctctcts
économiques majeurs.
Le commerce stratégique avec
touché et les autorités
appellididididididide pour gérer
l'arrivée de centaines
de milliers de réfugiés.
guerre continue, si les combats
ntntntntntntntnt de notre front,
ça va générer de nouvelles
vagues de réfugiés. Ça va
les citoyens ukrainiens de venis
une situation vraiment tragique.
- Dans son musée rendaàààààààààs
kilomètres du territoire
autoproclamé de Transnistirie,
Ion Stefanita craint aussi queoe
de Moldaves à quitter leur
En trente ans, la Moldavie
a déjà perdu 1,5 millis,s,s,s,ss
de sa population. Ion, l
assure qu'il restera, malgré
les
- Je suis motivé de rester
et d'être toujours là.
Et j'espère que l'on va passerde
de l'Ukraine et po
et on doit rester toujours chez
à la maison.